from timcast.com Vice media has filed
for bankruptcy reached a deal with
creditors including Soros fund
management to purchase assets
do you can you guys guess how much money
they uh are going to be spending on
purchasing Vice
have you guys read this do you know what
the number is I do because the number is
200 million it's zero what it's zero
dollars wait say that one more time zero
Soros fund management and I think Forge
is the other company loaned Vice money
and vice has defaulted on those loans so
the acquisition comes with the loan as
credit towards the purchase so they're
calling it 225 million but that money
was given to him four years ago so
they're basically assuming ownership of
Vice because Vice is in default
that's a major implosion that's it's
it's just like get woke go your advice
weren't you yeah I was what do you think
of this this downfall I think Vice was
this edgy punk rock brand that everybody
wanted to work at and one by one they
excised from the company people who made
it fun and brought in stodgy woke
Psychopaths and turned the company in to
plastic garbage that nobody wanted to
associate with or read and this is what
you get from a 5.7 billion dollar
evaluation to nothing
hey man
sometimes woke things make money but
it's true but typically you get woke you
go broke I could not imagine what it
must be like to have driven Vice up to
5.7 billion dollars to be named as the
up-and-coming CEO of the hottest media
property who's now worth two billion
dollars to be listed in Forbes as a
billionaire and then only a few years
later to
zero to be fair I think the uh I think
Shane Smith is probably still worth tens
of millions of dollars so good for him I
don't think I'll have to worry about but
it must be crazy to work on something
for three or four I think four decades
yeah we're talking 30 some odd years
about 30 years
more than that actually yeah and then
just
have nothing to show for anything today
I mean great look the company's gonna
operate I think
the Soros fund management is going to
rip the company to shreds sell
everything off to recover their losses
you don't think they're going to build
it up again nope absolutely not it's a
it's a garbage property now Vice in when
I joined back in 2013 was the gold
standard the golden name in advertising
you wanted your ads on advice it was
young it was hip the kids were there now
it's like embarrassing to be associated
with Vice yeah who wants to run ads on
that and they got no other it's not only
that I wonder why it is they didn't do a
membership Drive thing like BuzzFeed
tried to do sorry nobody wants to donate
to you Vice who wants to hang out with
the hall monitor I'm not gonna be paying
for fake news that's for sure like who
wants to hang out with the people that
that employ people literally to monitor
what other people are doing and
tattletail on them if you say a naughty
word on the internet Vice will be there
you have a shitty opinion Vice will be
there to tell everybody and monetize
your dumb idea they're it's good
riddance to bad rubbish does vices
collapse create a vacuum that another
company is going to fill like is there a
is there a runner-up device my opinion
is no but I'm not but I I don't see any
uh I don't see that that it was kind of
unique in its origin yeah but it's not
it doesn't it the true vacuum I think
that um that we lose out on I I love the
vice documentaries on YouTube for for a
while those are really really good no
matter what the subject was their
website after you know a few years
recently became hot trash but I know I
still haven't seen that kind of
replication of documentaries in a while
right that's what I think I think there
is a space where Vice way back in the
day really dominated and that's why they
had this fresh attractive reputation
it's not it's not like there's anything
that's going to be it's not like they
they had a position that needs to be
filled now like currently they haven't
been new and irreverent and risk-taking
in many years like the Tucker vacuum
yeah it's not exactly it's not like the
Tucker vacuum I mean granted it's a
totally different you know Arena Tucker
and vice but still there's no it's not
like Vice has been doing anything that
you know and Media Matters or whoever
like that's all it is it's like Vice and
Media Matters were the same people
they're all interchangeable because
their opinions were all the same with
and the same thing with CNN and and
MSNBC The the things the people that you
would see on like msnbc's website that
don't make it to the air on their their
cable channel would would absolutely be
the same people that you would see
writing for vice or see doing stuff or
vice so it doesn't really matter you
know who it is it's not like there's
going to be missing you know they
weren't people weren't watching for a
reason you know do you think people are
craving that kind of uh content and
information in this day and age like the
device documentary sphere I think so I
mean they were I didn't know that I was
looking for that kind of content when I
first found it but it definitely
captured the attention and unfortunately
what captured the attention nowadays is
video is like Tick Tock uh or or you
know weird but you know Vox
documentaries now
um but there there is there is that
vacuum and I I do remember it also
reminds me of Netflix in the early days
when their early documentaries were you
know their original series were pretty
interesting stuff but now it's just all
these obama-funded movies that you know
I'm not going to be watching soon so
there is a vacuum that they that is
created by Vice do you think it's the
the corporate structure that takes out
that unique perspective or do you think
just as as the company gets bigger they
change what they're interested in
promoting yeah well I think based off
what Tim says that's definitely the case
and I see with a lot of these YouTube
content creators as well where they they
start a channel that balloons into a you
know multi-billion or multi-million
dollar business and then they have to by
the by the virtue of their growth get
you know some of these you know
corporate heads involved in it Strays
away from what the original Spirit of
the content was and yeah I definitely
think that's what happened to advice do
you find that's true in your line of
work like working for a congressman do
you think your messaging changes each
year or do you think it's like pretty
consistent no I think it's consistent I
mean it's pretty easy when you just have
to listen to the American people and
reflect what they feel and you don't
have when you first started working with
Gates did you have to kind of learn his
tone or did you feel like you personally
already no I I no I my tone is the Maga
movement you know I'm a I'm a warrior of
you know the ultramaga folks out in the
country and so I I honestly think that
how I feel is how a large majority of
our people feel and so it wasn't ever
hard for me to wonder what the American
people thinks on an issue you kind of
just get it
um and you know if I don't if I had
thoughts on a certain issue go back to
the just go back to the district and see
what the constituents think yeah that's
interesting do you think that Netflix or
vice would have benefited from being
gonna do that like going back to their
audience and saying what do you want us
to be doing
yeah I think so but I think ultimately
Money Talks yeah I think so too are you
guys on Tick Tock no over at Matt Gates
good God no absolutely not well Tick
Tock is an entity of the CCP so we're
never going to be on Tick Tock probably
all of gen Z is it is true well I I
don't want to be there I don't want to
Aid in a bet Tick Tock so fair I think
regardless uh it is a I do feel it as a
uh as a comms director wanting to get
that audience but you know at the same
time you have to think about what you're
benefiting and I think ultimately there
are just too much of a too much of an
evil for me to be able to participate in
and I'll find Avenues elsewhere that
that organization gen Z for change says
that 40 of gen Z gets their news from
Tick Tock and Instagram
that's why Tick Tock bans people who go
against the establishment they are
trying to realign politics and I think
we should ban tick tock I agree and
there's a certain reason why they
operate Tick Tock how they do in the
United States and they operate a
different way in China it's a different
company in China their version and
something else but I think if you look
at vice vice is what happens when the
market has an opportunity to decide
whether or not woke content should
survive the answer is no Tick Tock is
what happens when the market doesn't
it just becomes the dominant app and
then they start removing any and all
competition politically
but nobody wants this stuff
I just man
the end of an error man do you think
that there's a replacement device nope
no you don't think there was like
someone picking up the timcast news yeah
maybe maybe we can start doing uh some
fun travel Adventure documentary stuff
yeah well your say has been totally
revitalized I believe I think I've seen
Tim cast news more on my feed than I
have at any other point I mean we just
we just do our thing you know Hannah
Claire writes stuff
me and all of the other journalists
that's great follow at timcast news on
Twitter and Instagram thank you I'm so
glad that you do that Vice wasn't always
news Vice used to be sex drugs and rock
and roll it was the underground so when
they started doing these travel shows it
was still just the underground it was
like traveling to a foreign place to
follow some crazy story and meet some
crazy people they weren't the biggest
stories in the world they would go and
meet a guy who sold shrunken heads and
it's like whoa what a crazy story it
reminds me more of what like Shane
Cashman does you know he's interested
and he pursues pursues it wherever it
goes I mean his story about finding
Confederate gold like that's not
mainstream news on the other hand it
gives you such an insight into the world
around you and especially Niche
communities maybe we should just do that
we'll send Shane on little adventures of
the camera and send Hannah Claire to
North Care uh North Korea just send me
to North Carolina that's like North
Carolina
two hours yeah three hours five I think
it's five politely yeah bill doesn't
expect me to go too far come back and
report for the show right I'm like live
on the ground reporting from North
Carolina go to North Carolina here it is
tell me are the mountains actually as
Misty as they said right well I mean I
think about this when I first moved to
West Virginia if I always talk about
um Mothman right and you can drive
across the state of West Virginia and
see the town that is incorporated into
Legend of I mean every state has sort of
their own weird weird histories and and
small conflicts that you can find a lot
of stuff that isn't uh filling this
breaking new space you know I like
writing about policy and I like being
able to write out there I'm really
grateful for the flexibility I have but
you know
sometimes there are issues that people
don't necessarily care about until you
write a compelling story about them and
again like I'm going to shout out Shane
Cashman here I think that's something he
does really well
um there are stories that aren't urgent
but at the same time if you read them it
can really shape your perspective and I
think that's what you're saying what's
interesting about the vice documentaries
you should definitely check out Shane's
uh uh part on on riffraff Riff Raff's
hilarious so thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time